the Joe Rogan experience how long can we
go I mean what if you if let's take
economics out of it what would you think
if there was no concern whatsoever about
economic loss and the damage to the
economy what would you recommend in
terms of just from clearly just purely
from a medical perspective well the
problem is from the medical and public
health perspective we don't really know
where this virus is heading you know
it's uh I figured what dr. fraud she
said the virus makes the decisions we
don't make the decision so although not
entirely true because we can make we can
enact an intervention so hopefully by
the summer this is not going to be a
huge problem but what we don't know and
then we also don't know if this thing's
coming back so what are the out-years
look like is this does the even if it
goes down this summer does it does it
come back up again in the fall does it
come back up again early
what's that why would that happen why
would it come back why would it why
would it go away and then come back in
the fall well there's a few things that
are happening one all the social
distancing potentially could interrupt
the transmission we use this number
called a reproductive number which
describes the number of people that get
infected if a single individual has it
so the number right now is between 2 & 4
depending on whose numbers you look at
the idea is you bring that below one by
the social distancing there's also the
question of whether there's seasonality
to the to this virus and again this guy
mark lipstick has done some studies to
show that there there seems the virus
infection doesn't seem to be as severe
in areas that have higher temperatures
and greater humidity it's a bit of a
soft call but maybe there's going to be
some seasonality to this as well and
then and so let's use an example of
another seasonal virus influenza you
know which Peaks of course in the winter
and then goes down in the summer months
it never really disappears but it it it
goes down but then in the southern
hemisphere it's the opposite so in the
southern hemisphere
peak flu season is our summer their
winter in places like Australia and then
in the tropics it's about the same all
year round so we don't really understand
seasonality potentially the virus could
start showing a pattern like that and
then the question is does a come back
year after year after year like flu does
or or and have shows some kind of
seasonality these are all scenarios that
that are being looked at so for instance
our vaccine if it's used and goes you
know goes through all the clinical
testing hurdles probably is not going to
be used for this 2020 epidemic if it's
used at all it's going to be used in the
out-years
if this virus starts to come back on a
regular basis
[Applause]